دعنا نستمع إلى ما يقولونه هو
أنهم يقتربون من البطة لأن البطة
لا تزال ترى محاذاة جيدة
تحت ثلاثة أمتار
حلقة تتحدث ذاتيًا من التنين في الأعلى
يوجد محول إرساء دولي
على الجراء اليمنى
مترين مترين سمعنا قطع الاتصال بأيدي الطاقم
خارج
نقطة جاري
مترًا واحدًا للذهاب إلى
dragon spacex على جهة الاتصال ذات الحلقة الكبيرة ، فإن
الالتقاط الناعم للتوهين الكامل في
التقدم ،
تسعى الفيزياء إلى
رأس المال على
ما يرام ، لذلك مع هذا الاتصال
والتقاط يأتي في الساعة 7 29 صباحًا بالتوقيت المركزي
5 29 صباحًا شرقًا هو 12 29 utc
بينما المحطة  طار والتنين 258
ميلًا قانونيًا فوق المحيط الأطلسي المركزي ،
لذا مع هذا
الاتصال الأولي ، ستبدأ حلقة الالتقاط اللينة
الآن في التراجع
مباشرة والتي تكون في الأساس على قدرة كبيرة
على البدء في التقاط الجاذبية قيد
التقدم